and there are four different types of uh
things that the church looks for
that would validate that perhaps is
truly a something demonic number one
would be the ability to speak and
understand languages otherwise unknown
to the individual
having superhuman strength beyond the
normal capacity of the individual
having elevated perception knowledge
about things that the person should not
otherwise know
and then four probably the one that most
people are familiar with an aversion to
anything of a sacred nature such as
having scripture read in front of them
being blessed with holy water being
shown a crucifix the things that people
probably are familiar with simply by
watching movies and whatnot on exorcism
so so the four things was superpower a
language that they should not speak
access to information that they normally
shouldn't have and then the fourth one
is what the priest does or them like how
they respond to holy water
aversion to anything right spiritual um
in the christian church and um are you
familiar with dr carl payne
no i'm not no you know carl payne wrote
a a wonderful book on uh spiritual
warfare from non-denominational
christian perspective so it doesn't
contain anything like from the
presbyterian the southern baptist
convention it's just non-denominational
bible interpretation and one of the
things he pointed out was that something
as simple as reading
first john 4 and saying you know every
um this is how you recognize the spirit
of god you know every spirit that
acknowledged that jesus christ has come
into flesh is from god every spirit that
does not acknowledge jesus christ is not
and
people have a strong resistance to that
those particular verses that are that
are calling on that with the power
and
you know
when
helping people with demonization
um it's exactly as you say
and but you can avoid you can avoid the
sensational reaction of them by setting
ground rules and asking for the covering
of the holy spirit have you ever
witnessed this before i've not witnessed
this before but i've talked to three
people that that um
have you ever had anybody in your life
what but this goes to all of tyler this
goes to you and to you have you guys
ever seen anybody in your life where you
said this person may be possessed yeah
absolutely you've had somebody yes
absolutely and you witnessed it like you
you knew this person or was it a person
that person knew it was my friend's mom
and i i witnessed her in a
and she was not drugs she was in hospice
but she was not being given morphine or
anything of the of the sort so she was
unmedicated have you witnessed anybody
yeah it just turns out that they were on
bath salts okay how about yourself no no
you never have okay so so
i have witnessed a close relative
that would say i put a curse on that
person okay i put a curse on that person
and watch what's going to happen to that
person and i've seen a person
behavior
act in a weird way so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]